[Musik]
hast du die geschrieben heute in
schönschrift
wow die ist echt schön
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es mal wieder ein schnelles
herzhaftes rezept ich weiß noch dass ich
vor einiger zeit mal ein maggi fix
nachgemacht nach gemacht habe wenn ich
muss persönlich sagen ich kaufe keine
fertigt tüten habe ich auch noch nie
gemacht aber ich weiß dass es viele
machen einfach aus zeitlichen gründen
und es ist ja auch gar nichts
verwerfliches daran denn vielleicht hat
man mal die zeit nicht gut ich kann es
nicht nachvollziehen weil ich nur so
denkt okay war kann ja auch einfach
alles in die pfanne und würzen weil für
mich ist eigentlich nur das hat mit
gewürzmischung aber es gibt ja menschen
diesen im kochen und backen vielleicht
eben nicht so haben und vielleicht auch
nicht wissen wie man was kombiniert und
eben zeitliche gründe man hat vielleicht
auch nicht so viele lebensmittel immer
zu hause und deswegen ist es ja wirklich
völlig okay für jeden muss was geben es
gibt ob mischungen und und vorgekochte
dinge und wie gesagt da müsst ihr euch
auch gar nicht schlecht fühlen und dürft
euch das auch von keinem schlechtreden
lassen auch nicht von mir deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht mach' ich heute mal
wieder in magix nachgemacht und zwar
habe ich mir ausgesucht polonaise bianco
also eine helle polonaise mit
champignons und da muss man im prinzip
einfach nur ich sage ganz oft prinzip es
tut mir echt leid aber
egal
da muss man
lediglich
spaghetti hackfleisch an bildungs und
schmand zufügen und ich habe jetzt
hinten noch gelesen zwiebel oregano ist
drin ein bisschen rosmarin und daraus
habe ich mir jetzt hier diese zutaten
rausgesucht und wehrt euch jetzt das
rezept kochen und es wird achtung da
steht doch bestimmt auch drauf wie lange
es dauert ich würde jetzt mal sagen so
20 minuten
steht nicht drauf weil jeder
unterschiedlich schnell kocht drei
portionen und waren sehr ich mach
mehrere portionen ich verwende dafür 500
gramm hackfleisch zwei esslöffel
olivenöl mit zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe
250 gramm champignons ich habe jetzt
hier braune und weiße gemischt 20 gramm
mehl 300 milliliter wasser etwas salz
pfeffer auch egal 200 und 500 gramm
spaghetti und hier habe ich noch
rosmarin und eigentlich noch
schnittlauch aber das hier ist dieser
knobloch schnittlauch china laut der
knopf braucht er nicht so heißt aber
jetzt in jedem meiner bücher steht mir
egal und das ist ja
da kann das auch jemand der so hieß
der bin mir studiert
jedenfalls schmeckt wie schnittlauch und
knoblauch gemischt und das ist echt sei
gut so
und das erste was jetzt mache ich nehme
die pfanne und
kann dann das olivenöl erwärmen und das
hackfleisch
schön krümelig anbraten so
habe gekleckert
ich mach das jetzt in zwei portionen
damit das hackfleisch schön heiß
angebraten wird
[Musik]
dann könnt ihr jetzt in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die zwiebel schälen und
schneiden
und die knoblauchzehe ich versuche dafür
im wasser aber du darfst mich nicht zum
lachen bringen denn sonst
spucke
[Musik]
sally
ganz die beatbox
funktioniert
es ist ein mythos mit wachsam und das
funktioniert nicht
ich meine was kann man da schon
großartig daran falsch machen oder
wow meine augen
das hat nicht geklappt aber hat nicht
aber jemand gesagt host brot essen oder
so aber ich meine hier ist doch kein
toastbrot wenn ich dann was koche
zunge rausstrecken mache ich aus
ich habe neulich so ein riegel 10 da hat
eine gute aufgabe so ein kapuzenpulli
und hat einen durchsichtigen topfdeckel
vorher eingespannt
wow
ganzes vorstellen ja du bist du eine
taucherglocke ist das okay server ist
der wichtiger
aber wäre jetzt kommen die zwiebel und
knoblauch erfüllt ihr dazu
übrigens ist es immer so und das werden
jetzt die italiener bestätigen können
dass immer die soße zuerst fertig
gestellt wird und dann werden die nudeln
gekocht also nie anders herum machen
weil die nudeln einfach immer kurz vor
dem essen eben gekocht werden und da
muss ich ein bisschen die verpackung
kritisieren da steht nämlich drauf
nudeln kochen und dann praktisch soße
zubereiten ich denke ich mir so ewig
leben dann zusammen und werden kalt und
sind vielleicht zu weich und so schnell
kann man das ja gar nicht kochen
naja bei
alten herren kann man noch sagen
nudelwasser aufsetzen weil es dauert ja
sonst ewig aber induktion geht schnell
ok man kann jetzt noch die champignons
klein schneiden und ich glaube ich halte
ich schmeiße scheiben
dann brate ich das einfach 23 minuten
mit an mit den zwiebeln und dem
hackfleisch
[Musik]
vielleicht hätte man eine größere pfanne
nehmen können
ich wollte aber weil die so schön ist
bis foto hab ich jetzt einfach fürs foto
wir reden darüber
wird schön anbraten für die tollen rest
aromen
ja guck mal das passt doch jetzt in die
pfanne
sehr gut und jetzt das mehl das dienst
der bindung
auch so ein bisschen mitrösten
und dann könnt ihr es direkt schon
ablöschen und wenn jetzt hier unten am
gusseisen ich wenn ihr könnt ja auch
andere pfannen oder töpfe benutzen aber
wenn jetzt beim gusseisen einfach was
bisschen anklebt oder anderen das ist
gar nicht schlimm denn ich löste sich
dann durch das wasser eben wieder ab und
generell kann man sagen gerade so
gerichtet die röstaromen bekommen sollen
sind in gusseisen oder eintöpfen echt
schon besser da bekommt man guten
geschmack mit rein
und jetzt schön ablöschen der gründerin
weißwein zum beispiel verwenden wenn ihr
ein bisschen kräftigeren geschmack haben
wollte
schön und
der rest ist dann echt nur noch
zusammenmischen
salz oregano pfeffer
jetzt habe ich auch schon nudelwasser
aufgesetzt
schmandt rühre ich noch rein und dann
ist es fertig ist einfach noch kurz ein
zwei minuten köcheln lassen ihr könnt
auch tatsächlich dann wenn er beim
zwiebeln anbraten seit die nudeln kochen
und dann ist es gleich gleichzeitig
fertig
schmandt noch dazu
und jetzt ist es eine polonaise bianco
also den rosmarin lege ich jetzt noch
mit rein der dazu ein bisschen mit
köcheln und dem knoblauch
jenal auch okay den haag ich wein und
den sträuchern später drüber
habe jetzt zeit hier aufzuräumen und die
nudeln zu kochen und dann probieren wir
mal mein maggi fix gericht
was
das sind nicht überkochen
und ja ich habe es jetzt nicht mit
weißwein oder so abgelöscht mir fehlt
ein bisschen säure muss ich sagen
deswegen packe ich da jetzt einfach so
ein bisschen weißen er sich dazu und
dann ist die soße perfekt den rosmarin
dann einfach entfernen kurz vor verzehr
[Musik]
gehört die nudeln sind perfekt programm
ist dort probieren
es gibt heute pizza würde ich sagen hat
pasta bolognese bianco ein nachgemacht
rezept von magie
mit
ja habe ich gar nicht probiert ich auch
noch stoße fertig sachen also dass wir
können das nicht aber also die einzigen
dann werd ich sagen was ich koste diese
fünf minuten
das war's aber sonst nichts sagen selbst
problem an und
ich richte das hier jetzt noch schön für
die bilder an ich bin tatsächlich auch
ein fan davon dass man nudeln mit der
sauce direkt vermischt
ich finde das schon immer ein special
dann zieht es schön ein ja
ich mache haben
vielleicht können wir erst mal so nudel
basic video machen weil wir uns grad
backstage vorbehalten das perfekte
nudeln sind und für mich sind perfekte
nudeln perfekt gar aber auch perfekt
gesalzen oder ich hasse nudeln die
einfach zu wenig salz haben und dann
gibt's ja menschen die schrecken nudeln
nach dem kochen ab damit einfach der
garpunkt so praktisch beendet wird aber
dann verlieren sie auch wieder geschmack
da bin ich gar kein fan dann gibt es die
die sagen öl noch dran aber dann haftet
die soße nicht mehr dran deswegen habe
ich mir immer so einen becher voll
nudelwasser auf es gibt so alles ich
finde butter oder aber immer bestritten
so kann es unserem budget ja dass ich
weiß nichts machen echt viele
und
also ich weiß nicht wie das morgen fix
schmeckt ja auch gerade abgeschmeckt ich
finde es auch richtig und guckt wenn man
so nudelwasser darüber gibt dann kleben
die nicht mehr
und dann brauchen wir keine wahl durch
das öl haftet hat keine soße deswegen
gebe ich das immer gerne auf jetzt kann
ich das hier noch schön anrichten und
ihr dürft das rezept gerne ausprobieren
und vielleicht gibt es das ein oder
andere fertiggerichte was ihr gerne ist
und sagt komm mach doch mal ein rezept
dazu dann schreibt gerne in die
kommentare
ja ich finde es war ein schnelles
trotzdem habe ich mich so aufwendig
und wenn ihr mal so nudel koch basics
sehen wollte das auch gerne
kocht jemand mal die note auf jeden also
bis zum nächsten mal
und jetzt richtig das tat er in amerika
so schöne fotos machen
ich mache so kleinen westchen
setzt die hier so rein und dann kommt
ein knobloch drauf
und bestimmt jetzt marcel wieder so ein
wikipedia-eintrag rein knoblauch
existiert nicht das heißt china auch
egal
[Musik]
la la la la la la la la la
frederico
mirakulös maggi fix ist fertig
[Musik]